tous ils sont partis samedi de marioupol
ils viennent enfin d'arriver en lieu sûr
en zone ukrainienne azapo ridja et c'est
là que l'on retrouve taille de kayes
notre envoyé spécial bonjour tarek les
premiers bus de civils d'ukrainiens
viennent d'arriver ces personnes étaient
pour la plupart prises au piège dans l'
usine azoff talent à marioupol
tout à fait il s'agit de cinq bus qui
sont arrivés il ya moins de dix minutes
cinq bus savoir desquels des personnes
qui ont été évacuées de lusine de
dassault ce talent à marioupol des
civils donc il s'agit essentiellement de
femmes et d'enfants on n'a pas vu
d'hommes ce qui confirme ce qu'on nous
avait dit plus tôt les ces bus là ces
évacuations concernent donc
essentiellement et uniquement les femmes
et des enfants et tous ceux qui ont
moins de 18 ans qu'on a vu ce sont des
visages extrêmement fatigué des visages
pâles d'un mot voyez toute la fatigue
qui avait derrière ces mois passés dans
l'usiné dassault ce talent avec des
difficultés extrêmement importantes
qu'ont enduré toutes ces personnes là
derrière moi comme vous le voyez ces bus
viennent d'arriver il s'agit donc de 127
personnes au total dont 69 seulement
viennent du complexe d'aosta les 58
autres viennent de la région de
marioupol j'ai pu m'entretenir il ya
quelques minutes avec une des
responsables de l'onu qui a conduit
cette opération
je lui ai posé la question concernant le
retard derrière c'est l'arrivée de ces
personnes elle m'a répondu en disant
qu'il fallait comprendre que nous sommes
dans un contexte de guerre il s'agit
d'une opération qui a été extrêmement
difficile à monter à la parler de mines
qui se trouvait sur le passage des bus
il ya eu même également eu des attaques
au mortier ce qui explique donc tout ce
retard
avec l'arrivée donc dos au but ce qui
vient d'arriver il ya quelques instants
la russie terek qui est peut-être en
train de lancer l'assaut final sur cette
fameuse usine donc des obstacles puisque
moscou annoncent une offensive cet
après-midi offensive validé confirmée
par les ukrainiens
oui elle a été validée par le côté
ukrainien la vice première ministre en
personne était là il ya une demi heure
elle a parlé elle a confirmé ces
attaques russes qui ont visé à marioupol
est là à parler du reste des civils qui
se trouve toujours la voie puisqu'il
s'agit que d'une infime partie des
civils qui ont été évacués elle dit qui
a dit me la personne des femmes des
enfants des personnes âgées qui sont
sans médicaments sans eau des gens qui
veulent être sauvé quand j'ai posé la
question à la vice-première ministre
concernant le message qui serait
derrière les nouvelles frappes qui vise
la zone ce talent elle a répondu de la
manière suivante écoutons là
c'est l'idée de la fédération russe
bombardait l'ukraine jusqu'à la mort du
dernier soldat ukrainien jeu nous le
répétons encore une fois asos talent ne
peut pas être la cible principale de
poutine ce ne peut pas être sa cible
alors que des civils se trouvent
toujours là bas
en tant qu'officier de l'armée je
comprends que nos soldats ont des
positions de combat là bas mais nous
avons toujours des civils sur place
nous continuerons à le dire malgré tout
ce qui a été fait lors des deux derniers
jours par le biais des corridors
humanitaires
la question des civils à l'intérieur de
l'usiné dassault ce talent n'a toujours
pas été résolu il faut que le monde le
sache
voilà pour ses propos recueillis donc
par tarik kayes et luxe ragots merci à
vous deux envoyés spéciaux à zaporizhya
pour france 24